non
tha
regardez le silence est ce que j'ai fait
a détourné l'argent du fonds
régionalisation ans mais je plaisante
votre humanité copine gaspard ou la
bonne soirée qui se prépare matrix
d'accord dont vous n'êtes pas trop tron
film d'action on n'est ce pas des
pétards
bon voilà comment ça se passait ici
c'est chez moi est ce que quelqu'un a
quelque chose à dire oui madame
patrimoine social décent se situerait
plutôt dans les catégories mijote
moi j'avais plutôt dire amateurs
d'égaler leur train de faire nul matin
le vallégant dal magro peur de l'équipe
il reste à ma place non c'est pas
c'est quoi ce foutoir
il ne peut en rester qu'un je parle
évidemment de l'aspirateur nixon jean
pierre baudoin tu fais des cauchemars
tremblements ça qui sort de mon placard
que je demande
sur les épaules du grand format à la
tête d'airbus chine pointe a forcément
un message
c'est la réponse à toutes nos questions
se trouvent sur ses murs intérêt à
trouver le moyen de rallumer fait plus
de lumière
la question c'est quoi le délire là vous
êtes coincé avec nous dans une cellule
qui voyage dans l'espace et dans le
temps voulu dire qui traverse les
époques comme dan kalbac